short form video has become the latest
battleground in social media
and the three big players
tick tock instagram rails and youtube
shorts the next few years it will be
billions of dollars being poured into
these platforms trying to increase their
reach trying to increase the value for
advertisers so let's compare them and
see which one is winning over users so
far and which one might come out on top
tick tock was the first of the three to
burst onto the scene but before tick
tock there was vine a popular short
video service offered by twitter
[Applause]
vine was one of the first short video
platforms to really grab the attention
of young creators
after twitter just continued vine in
2017 it created a big gap in the market
that was primed for tick tock to exploit
tiktok enjoyed rapid growth in places
like the u.s and india and by february
2019 the app had been downloaded more
than a billion times on apple ios and
android according to app analytics site
sensor tower but in 2020 the narrative
started to change
america and other countries went into
lockdown because of the coronavirus
people started spending more time on
tick tock and
all of a sudden it seemed like the
scrutiny on tick tock also increased
president donald trump voiced concern
over the possibility that user data on
tick tock could be shared with the
chinese government through the app's
parent company bite dance we're looking
at tick tock we may be banning tick tock
he launched a lengthy
back and forth with tick tock and its
chinese parent bite dance that never
really reached resolution during his
presidency but had a really huge
destabilizing effect on
the app's position in the u.s at the
time tick-tock officials said that user
data was held in servers in the u.s and
singapore and wouldn't be shared in june
2020 india decided to ban tiktok that's
important because it presented a gap
for rivals like facebook and google's
youtube to try to offer their own
products in the market and sure enough
in late 2020 facebook and youtube
launched their own short video services
snapchat also entered the mix with
spotlight which offers a daily pool of
more than one million dollars to users
who create the most entertaining snaps
instagram and youtube already had large
built-in audiences and tick tock had
primed people to want this kind of short
form video when instagram and youtube
started rolling out their own services
they took off pretty quickly
meta hasn't said how many monthly users
interact with reels but instagram passed
two billion monthly active users last
year and in its april earnings call
chief executive mark zuckerberg said
reals already makes up more than 20 of
the time that people spend on instagram
google said in june that more than 1.5
billion people watch youtube shorts
every month tiktok said in september the
app had drawn more than one billion
monthly users third-party estimates have
shown that number as high as 1.6 billion
monthly users
the short video craze also inspired
pinterest to create watch last year
where users can scroll through short
videos and pictures netflix launched a
feature called fast laughs that serves
up short clips from netflix shows
and even twitter said in december that
it was testing out an updated explore
tab to allow users to scroll through
short form video tweets
so with all these options which platform
is the most popular among users tiktok
certainly seems like it's still in the
lead if you look at the user data from
digital intelligence companies similar
web people say they're spending more
time on tick tock than on the instagram
app or youtube platform that being said
reels and shorts are gaining very
quickly in a june survey by data
platform company in mar intelligence 44
of people picked tiktok as their
preferred short form video service
followed by 29 for youtube shorts and 20
for instagram reels
another measure of success for these
platforms
advertising revenue tick tock seems to
be the farthest along in
turning on advertising on the service
this year they're projected to make
about 12 billion dollars in advertising
revenue up from four billion dollars
last year tick tock partners with
e-commerce platforms like shopify to
help businesses advertise directly
through their shopify dashboards and
earlier this year in an effort to
attract more advertisers tick tock
enabled first and third party cookies on
top of its existing tools youtube shorts
only recently started allowing ads on
the service reels is also
more immature
turning on ads on the service but
they're quickly catching up their parent
companies google and meta are two of the
largest online advertising companies in
the world it's a fairly safe assumption
that they're putting a lot of effort
behind
getting digital ads on these services
and
making that a bigger part of their
growth story for the future
second place is still a close battle but
it appears that shorts is gaining fast
on tick-tock based on viewer data google
released in june shorts began rolling
out ads globally in may and google said
it would eventually allow companies to
make their ads shoppable like on tick
tock and reels it's still a little bit
early to tell how that is going but
youtube right now is looking for a new
source of growth
as revenue growth has been flagging so
they're putting a lot of work into
making shorts a big advertising platform
youtube shorts also has a unique
advantage it allows creators to use the
analytics tools on youtube's main
platform which provide data about who is
watching videos these tools help
creators work with brands and prove the
effectiveness of their sponsored content
but youtube shorts doesn't offer
creators the same special effects
options as tiktok this spring it rolled
out new features including one that lets
users turn snippets of existing youtube
videos into shorts but it's still
missing tools like this
which lets creators combine their video
with one from another user
it's harder to pinpoint where instagram
reels is in this race because meta has
been reluctant to release data about
monthly active users on reels but in its
july earnings call chief executive mark
zuckerberg said the company saw
in the time that people spent engaging
with reels across facebook and instagram
however this is the first time meta has
ever reported a decline in revenue down
almost one percent from the previous
year earlier this month meta said it is
reallocating resources from its facebook
news tab and newsletter platform
bulletin as part of a broader shift
towards short-form video content
creators that can compete with tiktok
the company also said facebook's home
feed will be more personalized featuring
reels and content driven by the
platform's algorithm
as the race continues tick tock remains
a concern for some u.s lawmakers and
users concerned about data privacy but
the company has taken steps to address
this
in june the company said that 100 of us
user traffic was being routed to its
partner oracle and tiktok said that
while it still uses its own u.s and
singapore data centers as backup it
expects to delete u.s user data from its
own data centers and migrate fully to
oracle servers but for now tick tock's
algorithm still seems to attract more
users among the short video platforms
and that might help it remain the front
runner in this race
[Music]